it's really really an internet
phenomenon they still don't realize I
sing what kind of fame they have brought
for a Western point of view it's kind of
a dream like oh yeah every band would
like to do that
my name is Eduardo Goodell Bush I am a
PhD student in anthropology ice to the
Clarins ban and the phenomenon around
there increasing world fame
[Music]
I see it I see the garden haha kliklak
annoy don't they go in son in a Civic
Improvement em I got to government own
balanca
they are I could prove then that people
hire for fair or ceremony
[Music]
[Music]
basically they are marching band which
combine element from Eastern music and
element from marching band in Tallinn
what they call durian basically marching
band from university or from military
they combine the two and cover top chart
hits so it's been like maybe seven years
that they do that and still they they
still do that just because they because
they like that table tam vong unnal even
good money but they lack in my hamburger
K a lot that that Hamlet doesn't get up
my dad the point is just to entertain
people and if they don't have and they
don't they don't want to play they don't
do that for money so that I really like
Oh
[Music]